mindfulness is about this it is about
finally waking up one day and saying I'm
the boss of being here I have a mind I
can do better with it than letting it
feel horror show and letting it scare me
all the time then letting it remind me
of everything that ever bothered me then
letting it worry about what will happen
10 years from now or 20 years from now
that's not fun if they say you're going
to give a talk all right A lot of people
the mind gets a little trouble before
that doesn't it oh my God what if I
forget my lines what if I can't say oh I
feel so stupid I only want to do this
this anybody's mind ever do that to them
doesn't that help you perform better no
it doesn't so I could just sit here for
the whole hour and a half and remind you
of how ridiculous it is what goes on and
says ahead and some people sit there and
say but it's beneficial to go over this
stuff yes if something happens to you
and you make a mistake sit down look at
it pay attention learn from it and for
God's sakes not for the next 20 years
why they do that if I hadn't done that
this would have happened you can't can't
tell me there's a benefit there is no
benefit it's just that you haven't
learned how to work with this thing
called mine
need motivation watch the top 10 believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I struggle to stay afloat I
quit I'm a business partner and the
thing that kept me motivated kept me
going was studying the stories of famous
successful entrepreneurs and in their
stories it gave me the hope the drive
the ambition the
thinking that maybe I can do it too that
extra bit of belief and I still need
their stories today and I'm honored to
share them with you here as well so
today let's learn from one of the best
and my take on this top 10 rules of
success enjoy
rule number two is let go of yourself
let go of yourself
let go of yourself this thing you call
yourself your preferences your desires
your needs your Buckle is and so on is
just a projection of the stuff you
stored inside but what do you mean if
you didn't have it you'd be filled with
love and filled with light you wouldn't
be asking any questions you'd love
having a child you'd love bring it up
and enjoy every moment of it if you
homeschool you don't homeschool it
doesn't make any difference everything
because you're fine and that's the
environment they grew up I always like
grew up in an environment where it's
just pure love and openness and
understanding and they have a problem
they bring it to you you don't say oh my
God what did I do what's it you just you
have Clarity you can share with them and
help them come to the solution
themselves right yeah so it's a healthy
thing because you're healthy so a parent
shouldn't sit there and say it's so hard
to bring with a child it's hard because
you didn't bring yourself up you didn't
let go of your own stuff right yeah so
it's it's there's so many things to
learn yeah it's all about you evolving
as a being as a being of light as a
being of energy and keep bringing
yourself up and letting go then you
spread that light everywhere that takes
care of business somebody wanted me to
because I did business and all the
business can you give us spiritual talk
on business right I generally will say
no I I don't want to focus like like
that right but the truth is I would give
the exact same talk right how do you run
a sense of business let go of yourself
then you're not making decisions based
on your garbage and your fears in a past
experiences and all that kind of junk
you're bringing good energy into it and
it will attract good energy and people
around you will work with good energy
and they'll enjoy working with you yeah
my company we're technical high-tech
very few people ever left they loved
working there yeah right and I didn't
pay him the top salaries either because
we're out here in the middle of the
woods right and basically you just
create an environment for business an
environment for children environment for
love an environment for everything you
do that brings Beauty and love and
Clarity and selflessness true
selflessness into your environment it
will change everything rule number three
is reach a state of Happiness what is
love Shakti the energy rising up to the
fourth chakra and pouring out the foot
chakra that's what you would call love
and to cut the tuning with somebody who
you like if if they talk the way you
want to dress the way you want act the
way you want etc etc you open and then
the energy can come up and you feel this
experience of love but what if you're
not closed what if you never close
that is all love you know it should take
for you to feel love anytime you want
just wave your hand in front of your
heart and Bliss pours for your heart all
the time anytime you want that is what
it means to reach a state of Happiness a
state of pure unconditional happiness
it's inside of you it's available to you
rule number four is accept challenges
the challenges of life are amazing
what's wrong with challenges we play
sports we like challenges nobody wants
to play a team that you beat 700 to 1
every time you play them you want to be
challenged you want to have to bring out
the best of your being
if you can get clean inside where you're
not being run by all these past
Impressions we call them some scars in
yoga all these past Impressions which
are telling you and they are telling you
constantly you can only be happy if this
happens and you can never be happy if it
doesn't and you will never be happy as
such as it happens and then you go out
into the world chasing this as opposed
to working inside on yourself to say I
don't need those conditions life is
amazing I'm sitting on a planet spitting
in the middle of nowhere's and there's
all these events happening don't worry
they won't last yeah I could stay here
but while you're here do you want to run
around and fight with life and people
and places and things and even the
weather to try to make it be what you
think you want
or do you want to work on yourself to
clean up this mess inside so you can be
open all the time that's what
spirituality is about it's not about
pronunciation it's pronunciation is too
late you've already decided that you
want something you need it to be happy
but you're not going to do it depth
spirituality is understanding you don't
need anything
you don't need anything doesn't mean you
don't do anything but you don't need
anything you're a whole and complete
within yourself if you open there is
tremendous Joy love inspiration that
Wells up inside of you the moment you
open the moment something happens that
you like watch how fast you feel Joy and
if something happens you don't like
watch how fast you close that is not
teaching you about the outside that's
teaching about the inside
that openness is where it's at closeness
is not open this is what you really want
because what does opening mean it's like
opening the blinds if you close the
blinds in your house your house is dark
it's like that chapter in the untethered
Soul take down the Walls if you close
the blinds in your house your house is
dark now you have to run around with
artificial light trying to figure out
how to get some light if you open the
blinds you don't have to do anything the
light is coming in but you won't open
the blinds until you're sure nobody's
out there and only the right people are
in your house and everything's exactly
what you want you're afraid to open the
binds you don't feel comfortable so you
either decide to spend your life trying
to build artificial light inside or you
decide to work on yourself so you want
to leave the blinds open yoga true
spirituality is about taking off the
blinds take them off the windowsill
throw them out and never ever close them
ever again what is the purpose of
closing it makes you sad it makes you
dark what is depression total darkness
total closeness you have closed off to
the flow of the energy there is no
reason for that there is no excuse for
that this is your world inside it's your
mind it's your heart it is your
responsibility to not close it how dare
you think you're going to meet somebody
who will overcome your tendency to close
I want a job don't give me that job
you're going to know your whole life
building all these Impressions that
bother you or scare you and turn you on
and then you say to me as a relationship
that it's my responsibility to keep your
mind open and your heart open when
you're in there closing it all the time
I hope that seems silly and
counterproductive it is your
responsibility to keep your mind open it
is your responsibility to keep your
heart open and once you learn to do that
they're your mind and your heart once
you learn to do that you will feel Joy
all the time and I mean all the time
from the moment you wake up in the
morning you'll be inspired you'll love
to go to work even if you went to the
same job for 30 years you don't ever get
bored why because just energy flowing up
inside of you you will get the most out
of your relationships you'll be able to
give the most to all moments that are
fully in front of you why because now
you're a giver instead of a taker when
we come into the moment into interaction
with the moments in front of us we're
looking to see what we can get we're
looking to see how we want them to be
we're speaking to change things we're
dressing certain ways we're doing all
kinds of things to manipulate the
moments so that they will be the way we
want and when they come inside they'll
turn us on a being who has learned to be
open all the time never does that they
don't need to do that because they're
already feeling what they want to feel
they're feeling Joy they're feeling love
they're feeling inspiration
so now when the momentum Falls in front
of them they can give to it they can
take this joy and love that they have
and they can then shine it upon the
moment people place them things that are
unfolding so this is spirituality also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is overcome
negative thoughts there's always a voice
in my mind oh I'm crazy like I'm doing
something that's wrong I'm going to be a
gigantic failure like you know people
will look at your laugh at you and all
that but I think those voices are I mean
you talked about actually in all three
books about the preferences and things
you like the how our mind works
um I think it's pretty common yeah have
you had those voices and how do you deal
with this voice well and I explained at
the beginning of the surrender
experiment yeah that's how I started my
spiritual journey is I was sitting on a
couch with a friend of mine back in who
knows 69 70 maybe and uh there was a
lull in the conversation and
somehow that's not comfortable even with
friends you know that you were talking
and then there's nothing to say and you
try to think of things to say to keep
the conversation go the conversation
about feeling comfortable yeah it's
really about control because you have a
certain amount of control that you know
this person is interacting with you
they're okay yeah you know what I'm
talking about all right yeah and so I
noticed that that was going on inside my
head that he was anxious even with a
friend all right that there was this
sense of discomfort in the silence yeah
and Mickey Michael was trying to think
what to say to this day I was 52 years
ago I remember the whole exact moment or
where it is and he's sitting there
saying uh it's kind of hot out isn't it
or would you like to get something to
eat maybe we get a pizza Jesse he kept
saying these things yeah and inside I
noticed that that's going on in my mind
they all seem very stupid to say and I
didn't save him for the first time in my
life I didn't go along with that no
process was what the mind was saying and
then I realized who am I that is
noticing the mind saying that and as
simple and silly that seems that guided
the rest of my life period that moment
woke me up to realize wait a minute it's
always talking
right as I was trying to figure out
whether to eat or something it's always
saying something it's busy judging when
thinking and liking and not liking and
figuring out what to do yeah but now I'm
not it I'm watching it do that yeah
right Awakening to witness Consciousness
but I had no background I'd never met
anybody yeah
nothing yeah nothing yeah it just
happened okay and I'm watching it and I
started to feel I don't want to be that
I don't want to be like that yeah right
yeah and so I remember the first thing I
said instead of do you want to do this
should we do this so I'm watching this
voice inside my head telling me what to
say but I'm feeling distant from it for
the first time in my life and so instead
of saying when I finally talked I didn't
say where do you want to go what do you
want to do isn't it hot you know do you
remember what Nixon did the other day or
something I sat there and said I have
this voice inside my head talking do you
have one and as I said to him and he was
a famous lawyer he was my brother-in-law
at the time and he was a big lawyer in
Chicago and they never thought about
these kind of things and basically he
looked at me and he looked at me strange
with this kind of look and then all of a
sudden bam this light went on in his
eyes it was so beautiful a light when I
said yeah I know just what you're
talking about my my never shuts up and
there it was that was and the rest of
all my years I mean it stopped so I
don't have to work with as much but
everything was about that voice yeah
right so you're talking about how yours
was telling you you can't do this my
whole thing from that moment forward was
wait a minute I don't need this Chunk on
the side of my head yeah it's so
distracting it's so negative it tends to
be negative right and so on so by the
time I was building the house I had
started to work with that voice and this
I started working with the town to shut
up
shut up shut up I don't want to talk to
you right then you realize that the
voice telling the voice to shut up yeah
it took it took quite a while for me to
wake up to realize how to work with that
right but at that time I was not
listening to it if it said you can't
build that house I said shut up
which is not the right way do not do the
president that is not the right way to
deal with that voice in your head all
right but so it wasn't a problem because
I wasn't listening to it yeah so I was
just letting this unfold as it was
happening yeah and putting my whole
heart and soul into this is what I need
to do to get to where I want to go right
so I'm going to do it yeah there's no
complaining no this no that yeah so
that's the answer rule number six is
perfect your relationships with others
one opportunity that always presents
itself constantly in a workplace
is perfecting your interaction with
other people
it's a relationship just like your
personal relationships that you have at
home you have relationships with every
single person you're interacting with
and we need to learn to perfect those
and by perfecting those we'll perfect
ourselves why what happens naturally as
we've discussed earlier is we've had
experience in our lives
those experiences have carved you
they've carved your sense of good and
bad and and what you like and what you
don't like what you're afraid of and
what you desire Etc these are not things
you decided there are things that your
environment and your experiences left
these Impressions these Impressions got
left on top of you so now what happens
is when you look out into the world what
you see is yourself you know that you've
all heard that before so you look
outside because you're looking through
the glasses of your own personal
experiences everything looks that way
well that's not a good foundation for
working with other people and what
you're going to find out is that you
become very critical of other people so
if you're a boss when you look at other
people you think that your employees
they should be doing things the way you
thought the way you do them
so what it comes down to is how do I use
my interaction with the people in my
Workforce in my workplace to perfect
myself so that I learn how to get along
with people that are different than me
the beauty of when you go home there's a
handful of people you know one two three
your family when you go to the workplace
there's lots of people and so you get
this tremendous opportunity
to learn how to work with diversity
people are diverse
so how do I go about working with people
first you start by neutralizing yourself
you realize that your view of how it
should be done what everything is is
just your view so you try to listen say
what other people are trying to say
through their actions about how they
would go about doing it now I can give
you a nice talk about how everybody has
contribution ever has something to give
and just give them an opportunity let's
say you're past that and what you see is
that things are not being done in a way
that is constructive or ultimately
constructive or ultimately efficient
you're the boss you're somebody in a
position that's your responsibility to
get things running as good as possible
as even as smooth and effective as
possible efficient as possible so how do
I deal now with a person who's going
about their business and it's not coming
out that way I look at it as an
opportunity to perfect the universe it
is not something against the other
person I'm not criticizing the other
person even Within Myself they're not
doing anything wrong the universe
created them they are the result of
everything that caused them to be the
way they are everything's that way and
I've now been put in a position where I
can help to raise the universe to help
it run more smoothly help it run better
so you start off with a constructive
view that if something is not perfect in
front of you that's a good thing that's
an opportunity for you it doesn't get
you upset doesn't make you frustrated it
doesn't make you angry therefore when
you approach the other person you're not
putting them on a defensive point of
view if you cause defensiveness in
another person you've not done your job
because nobody does good based on
defensive or fear that is not a
foundation for good work so basically
you approach it from the point of view
of that person is me and I have these
blockages I have this inability to see
something how do I work with myself how
do I change this and a lot of times
you'll end up working with a person not
even about the thing that you want to
talk about you start working at another
level with the person and help them work
through what issues they have that are
causing them to be the way they are and
it becomes a friendship it becomes a
beautiful experience you find that your
entire interaction with every single
person in your life is giving you are
serving that's all you're doing it is
your job to help it be the best that it
can be they're not serving you I'm CEO
of accompanied all these people they're
not serving me I'm here to serve them
I'm here to help them be better rule
number seven is get in harmony with life
once you get comfortable being with
reality this is very deep this is what
loud Sue tried to talk about in the Dow
now that you are willing to let go of
yourself your personal self and interact
with reality your awareness is now
experiencing reality you will find that
there's not one single moment that
unfolds in front of you that is not
calling to you to interact with it it is
there you are there because you are
meant to be with each other that's how
perfect it is it's like the most perfect
relationship people looking for their
soul mates it's right front of you it's
called life it is the most perfect fit
for your being that's why you're there
and it's there and you will feel it and
you will know what to do I'm telling you
you will never ever have trouble making
a decision again for the rest of your
life you will never wonder you will
never have any angst or anything it'll
just be the universe it's sort of like
listen to me you're on the ocean on a
surfboard how do you know when to go up
and when to go down you don't the wave
does it for you you just ride the wave
the wave comes up you go up the wave
goes down you go down but what if I want
to go down when it goes up you fall what
if I want to go up when it goes down you
fall it's like you just interjected
yourself into a system that you're
supposed to be in harmony with and if
you are in harmony with it you will know
exactly what to do because it's telling
you what to do is that telling you with
words but it is telling you what to do
isn't it it's telling you what to do
it's a go to the right go to the left
feel it be in harmony with it that's how
you ride a wave that is the Dao that is
what laozu was talking about how you
ride life if you're not busy in there
wanting it to be other than it is then
you are in harmony me with what it is
the moments know where they're going
they're part of a Harmony that's moving
through time and space you are here to
experience that and participate in that
you don't have to do anything it is
happening to you you're happening with
it and then you're gonna see that what
happens you start just being with it and
everyone looks at you and says oh you're
so good at everything you do you're not
doing anything you're not doing a single
thing but you're neither doing nor not
doing that's the deepest of all the
teachings you are there with it it's
doing something the ocean is doing
something so obviously if you're on the
ocean and the ocean's doing something it
looks like you're doing something here's
what I just told you is the entire
bhagavad-gita it's the deepest teaching
you will ever even come close to
everyone will think you're doing things
you're not doing a single thing but
you're also not not doing either right
you are just being on the ocean and
being with it and the ocean knows where
it's going therefore you will be the one
who's in harmony with everything it's so
simple that we miss it if you want to
play baseball and you want to pick up
grounder I do not think that what you
should be doing is guessing where it's
going to go next you should be watching
it why because it knows where it's going
next you see that scene so weird you're
the smart one you should be the one who
can figure it out I guarantee you right
now that ball knows more about where
it's going than you do the ground and
the ball and the interacting with them
those way more about what's going to
happen next than anything you're going
to figure out that's why they say keep
your eye on the ball they don't say keep
your eye on your mind they don't say
that they say keep your eye on the ball
in every sport why because the ball
knows where it's going it just it's the
forces of nature therefore it knows
where it's going it is perfectly in
harmony with all the forces that it's
interacting with isn't it so if you keep
your eye on the ball you have a better
chance of being where it's going because
you're paying attention to where it's
going you're not guessing you're not
figuring you're not using logic you're
not worrying you're not angsting you're
not hoping you're not praying even a
good religious coach if you say coach
when the ball is hit should I close my
eyes and pray that I get it or should I
watch the ball they're gonna tell you to
forget the praying stuff at that time
pray that you can keep your eye on the
ball all right you're supposed to keep
your eye on the ball and it's the same
thing with life I'm telling you it's
exactly the same you come into harmony
with the moments that are unfolding in
front of you why would I do that I'm not
even gonna answer you if you're sat here
this long because they are the moments
who are sitting in front of me but if I
don't like them it has nothing to do
with like and dislike does it it has to
do with Dancing with it what I don't
like what the waves are doing then don't
surf because you're going to fall and
it's the same way with life rule number
eight is practice gratitude I'm here for
a little while on the planet Earth just
a very little time a few years and I get
to see I don't get to see much it's
really embarrassing I only get to see a
little tiny bit that's in front of me
and even a moment I miss everything else
you understand that those of you think
you know some you don't know anything
here's a book it's just the most
brilliant book read one word give me the
book back
do you know the book
here's a moment in life there are 700
billion quillion going on at the same
time you saw one you know what's going
on
though you don't know what's going on
you know the slightest idea was going on
you only know what you picked up so I
told you statistically where you picked
up is statistically insignificant
in fact it rounds to zero Plano
am I right or wrong you see it so
therefore what you picked up can't be
anything it's nothing it's zero
but you think it's everything and to you
it is everything because it's the only
thing you picked up your Universal set
is like nothing is just God I'm trying
to talk to you intelligently
so the right way to come into the moment
is to sit here and realize I'm a
conscious being that's a blessing
however it came from I don't know but
I'm here I know I'm here and I'm
conscious and there's this moment of
folding in front of me I am well aware
that there are 700 billion zillion going
on everywhere that I'm not experiencing
but I can't do anything about that let
me at least experience the one I'm
experiencing wow it's kind of neat let
me at least experience what I'm
experiencing like a gift this is the
gift that's being given to you there's
another gift being given to everybody
else there's seven billion people on the
planet Earth every single one of them
experience something different every
single moment
that's what they're experiencing that's
the gift that's being given to them and
so you actually come into the moment I'm
afraid to say it with a sense of Honor
with a sense of respect with a sense of
gratitude you sit there and say to the
moment wow thank you this is the one I
got to experience
has nothing to do with what I want what
I don't want and what should be or what
shouldn't be it has to do with my
humility of realizing I am not the
creator of the universe I am the
experiencer of this moment that's what I
am there are forces that are creating
the universe you do know that you want
to call them science I love you want to
call it God I love it makes no
difference just call it not me
that's the nicest name for the creator
of the universe not me because you know
it's not you don't you okay you just
gotta sit in here pick up the moment
that's in front of you then honor and
respect that experience rule number nine
is be kind to you you start by honoring
respecting and accepting the blessing
and the reality and the right of what is
unfolding in front of you if you don't
like it you look at that it's just
harmonious you let go of yourself and
that's Christ saying You must die to be
reborn we're talking about you literally
do the process don't get mad at yourself
for being a certain way just don't
participate in that part of your being
you don't have to get mad at your hand
because it wants to pick up a cigarette
just don't pick up the cigarette in fact
if you get mad at your hand you'll
probably be so stressful you will pick
up the cigarette then you definitely
need a cigarette and say they were
drinking just don't do it don't get mad
don't do anything just don't participate
in the process that will not take you
where you want to go so if you find
yourself make up an alternate reality I
am begging you to just let it go if you
find yourself not liking the reality
that's unfolding in front of you I am
begging you relax and let go all right
that's not the end of your relationship
with life that's the beginning of your
relationship with life and remember 10
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is value your experiences
your mind is a very great thing it is
brilliant it took metals and sand and
taught the sand to think and silicon and
took metals and made a rocket ship got
inside and flew to the moon
oh my God you are brilliant I have a
brilliant mind okay that's not the
problem the problem is what you're doing
with it when you go to that brilliant
mind you say I'm not okay because I
store all this junk inside of me figure
out how everybody else needs to be so I
can be okay
there's a total misuse of mine stop it
that's what you do that's your Technique
stop doing that don't use your mind for
that that's the personal mind don't use
your mind for that use your mind for
great things no use your mind for sick
things but then what do I do about the
fact that I'm not okay fix it
don't make everybody else be different
so you can be okay don't have all these
rules of how everything needs to be so
you feel better find out why you're not
okay how's that who to say work at the
root that's the root right well why am I
not okay I told you you just weren't
listening you're not okay because you
shoved all this stuff inside of you of
every single experience you ever had in
your life that bothered you they were
uncomfortable with they're going to be
things that are uncomfortable you see a
rattlesnake all coiled up rattling
that's not comfortable I probably should
have seen them all right that's supposed
to scare you you gotta say that's why
he's doing it it's not wrong it's not
bad it didn't ruin your life it's a heck
of an experience in fact does that mean
I should go pick it up no you respect
the experience you're having and then
you let it pass you're a greater being
because you had that experience every
experience you have makes you a greater
being because you had the experience I
don't know how to explain that to you
why do you practice tennis why why do
you when you practice tennis you just
have the ball you know the ball server
the boat but my server just have it come
exactly where your strength is every
single time so you can get better at
where you're strong now you hit it all
over the place why because every single
angle you get better because you use
those muscles and because you came in
too right or wrong practice makes
perfect well if practice makes perfect
in sports well I just practice not make
perfect in life
experience is your best teacher
therefore every single experience you
have you have it and it passes through
you don't hold on to the rattlesnake so
that you miss the next experiences honor
and respect the experiences you had
everyone the divorced to this the
children had children traumas I don't
care I'm serious stop it you're not a
victim
you're somebody who received the gift of
experience how's that the fact that it
wasn't comfortable with the rattlesnake
wasn't comfortable fine that's part of
the experience Let It Go I'm glad I had
that experience now I know better about
rattlesnakes I met one okay I know how
to deal with it well okay fine you've
met divorce your parents got divorced
wonderful you win the person whose
parents didn't get divorced they lost
they didn't get to have that experience
that's how you have to look at it every
single experience you have is it's
weight in gold it's a gift from God and
it's your gift because nobody else had
your experience so you process these let
them go that's your spiritual path if
meditation helps meditate Mantra helps
do Mantra but the purpose is not
meditation or Mantra or any other
techniques the purpose is are you
willing to stop storing inside of you
the things that were difficult when you
had the experience because otherwise you
store difficulty inside of you it's
going to be there all the time you
understand that you have a bad smell
don't collect them and take them home so
you put them in a room and remember how
bad it was and how much you didn't like
it just let it pass open the windows or
don't I don't know what to do when I get
a scrum kind you always forget but just
let it go and it'll be over it'll pass
don't never drive down that road again
don't
hear me let your experiences pass and
they will offend you you'll become a
whole person because you had them you
don't need to hold them in your mind
that is spirituality and now I showed
you why spirituality and life are the
same thing aren't they that's the
highest way to live your life that's the
highest way to become spiritual so find
a way to work with yourself inside
instead of trying to use your mind to
avoid yourself don't let your mind say
how you want things to be or not it's so
foreign to people no I want things to be
the way they are and what I want is to
be able to honor and respect the reality
of the moment in front of me that's the
last want that gets left that's your
work and you work on that one it's over
isn't it so little by little
work with the things that are unfolding
in front of you don't store them honor
them respect them let them pass and
because you're not putting more stuff
down there the old stuff will come up by
itself I promise you don't worry it will
you'll come complain the old stuff will
start coming up Let It Go
Let It Go you do not want any of it in
you let it go if it needs to come up Let
it welcome it sing hey come on up you're
welcome here kiss it throw a party
really tell you the worst stuff you have
in there welcome it up just relax and
release as it comes up and it'll go
it'll pass not all at once it'll pass
and where do you see I'm telling you
energy will come free inside
I wake up in the morning with ecstasy
pouring with your being that worries
about what happened
and then all through the day it feeds
you it rises up inside of you feeding
you all the time that's what your life's
supposed to be like
you can start with positive thinking
that's one level that at least you
should be doing that right you sit there
and say we'll make it through this and
even if I don't whatever it is I will be
a better person because of this if
you're in into God running everything if
that's your state God knows what he's
doing there are so many different things
that you can do with positive thinking
to create a nicer environment inside in
my opinion you have an obligation to do
that both for yourself for the health of
your body for people around you you just
lift yourself up like he just says one
should raise the selfless self not
trample down the self this is a time to
be doing that work so you can't say I
can't do that you can make your mind say
things you're going to use to say every
time there's a negative thought replace
it with a positive one it's a good time
to practice that so it's it's rolling
for itself oh my God this is terrible
I'll be fine this is okay God knows what
he's doing or you know there's just
reality it's just reality accept it
either way and then the next level is
you sit there and if you do Mantra and
mantras have to be an Eastern you know
Sanskrit Mantra but it just gets
something going behind that you're
hanging on to it a deeper part of your
mind I'll be okay this is okay I'll use
it whatever it is right then what will
happen is when the lower cell starts
these situations happen you just settle
back into it so you have a choice which
mind you want to listen to the lower
mind which we know what it's like or
you've built something beautiful inside
and then ultimately the highest state is
you relax every single time something
hits your stuff you relax you relax
relax and let go relaxing itself is
Letting Go people sometimes I say well I
relax how do I let go the very fact that
you chose to relax relax your shoulders
relax your tummy Etc and and just relax
inside you that is Letting Go you're not
getting all involved in what's going on
so that's the highest state is you just
keep letting go in the worst it is the
better is keep letting go you just to
commit yourself I'm going to use this
right then you of course put aside some
time in the morning and evening to
remind yourself that this is what I'm
doing mindfulness is about this it is
about finally waking up one day and
saying I'm the boss of being here I have
a mind I can do better with it than
letting it scare me all the time than
letting it remind me of everything never
bothered me it's not fun is it right and
to say you're going to give a talk in
your class all right A lot of people the
Mind get a little trouble before that
doesn't it oh my God what if I forget my
lines does anybody's mind ever do that
to them doesn't that help you perform
better no it doesn't so I could just sit
here for the whole hour and a half and
remind you of how ridiculous it is what
goes on inside your head right it is
worse than an arm that won't stop doing
this and some people sit there and say
they want to sit there and say but it's
beneficial to go over this stuff yes if
something happens to you and you make a
mistake sit down look at it pay
attention learn from it and for God's
sakes not for the next 20 years why they
do that I haven't done that this will
happen do you understand that you can't
tell me there's a benefit there is no
benefit it's just that you haven't
learned how to work with this thing
called mine you're trying to make your
Neurosis or your anxiety relax no
anxiety doesn't know how to relax
anxiety is anxious you're saying that
it's just nature right it's all jumpy
and stuff like that right but you who's
noticing it you has the hands in there
you can relax you can sit there and say
okay fine just relax and lean away from
the noise just go to that place okay
that is like a Zone
athletes talk about being in the zone
right there's a Zone inside if you relax
behind that noise there's a piece back
there there's a there's a quiet doesn't
be a big spiritual experience but it's a
heck of a lot nicer to hang out with
anxiety yeah it's the Observer that's
what it feels like you're the Observer
and you relax and if you do that over
time not immediately but over time you
you will find that that which was making
you anxious the Neurosis downstairs oh
my God my boss is going man I told him
I'd be there I'm going to be late you're
gonna be just as late anyways it's not
going to change the thing you look at
that and you realize I'm okay I'm okay
it doesn't do any good to show up
neurotic okay so you let go and as you
let go you'll notice amazing thing that
energy that was all weird because you
didn't touch it it changed it was able
to come up all right or you start using
affirmation right you sit there and say
oh come on this is probably a an older
person like my grandmother my grandma I
do yes yes
that's right they get to drive and I
should not be talking at them or
bothering them or even sending them bad
vibes maybe they should not be driving
any faster well and the point is it's
the latter part of their life and at
least they get to go some places and it
means a lot more to them than this
Neurosis means to me and you feel like
you're giving something instead of
demanding and taking you can change
yourself it's not about suppressing it's
not about denying it's about raising you
raise yourself pausing almost feels like
it generates compassion a little bit
what you'll find out is you back there
are the most beautiful thing in the
whole universe you are filled with love
you're filled with compassion you're
full of inspiration you're filled with
like well shock the energy the spirit
energy quote whatever you want filled
with it all the time but you're busy
looking down at this garbage and so you
learn to raise yourself the other
example that I like to use because I'm
very much into
being Broad and seeing the whole
universe instead of just your little
tiny world right is let's say it's hot
out nowadays we have global warming
we're hot okay it's very hot out you're
standing there and you have to go from
one place to another and you're actually
outside with no air conditioning isn't
that terrible and as you're walking
you're complaining oh my gosh so
freaking hot and I'm sweating I don't
want to sweat I don't like this sort of
thing and I always have to be so hot
what's wrong with these people Bubba
okay well that doesn't help anything it
doesn't make it cooler it doesn't do a
single thing it's the same thing like
the car but what if you sat there I know
I trained Mickey this I trained Michael
this way all right as I sit there and I
look and I say how did it get hot be
quiet how did it get hot what do you
mean why is it hot
well because there's a son out there you
mean there's a star 93 billion miles
away and you're it's hot it's so hot
that you feel it's heat here I'm in
Gainesville Florida Miami is about 300
miles away I asked them how big would a
fire have to be in Miami for you to
steal it in Gainesville if the whole
town caught fire you would not even know
what happened that thing's 93 million
you hear that it's 93 million miles away
and you can feel the star shine okay you
can feel is that means
yeah I could feel a star the stars are
neat things right and you start working
with yourself that way and it works you
raise yourself
Karma Yoga is about everything else
that's why Karma Yoga is the deepest
yoga it's not about your relationship
with your body with your heart with your
mind or even with your higher bodies
it's about your relationship with the
rest of the world with the rest of
what's unfolding in front of you how do
I interact with the reality of life that
keeps manifesting before me that is the
topic of Karma Yoga and it's often
considered the deepest yoga because it
is so expansive in one's life in fact
one of the deepest spiritual scriptures
in yoga the bhagavad-gita is considered
A Treatise on Karma Yoga
so what is karma yoga what is our
relationship with the world around us
in order to understand that to begin to
truly understand that you have to
understand two things one who are you
who's in there looking out what is the
nature of your being that has a
relationship with the world around you
and the second is what is the nature of
the world outside of you
first is actually quite simple
you are the one who's in there looking
out
this is what the essence of witness
Consciousness and Krishna murder used to
talk about objective observation
you're the indwelling being who looks
out through your eyes hears through your
ears you are the one who knows you have
a body you are the one that was in there
when you were six years old and when you
looked in the mirror you saw a
six-year-old's body now you see whatever
age you are and it will continue on you
are the Consciousness the awareness of
being you see the emotions that are
coming up from your heart you see the
thoughts that are created in your mind
and ultimately you experience great love
and sometimes Bliss as you get deeper
within yourself it's all the same you
there's just one of you there that's you
well what is the nature or the reality
of the world outside of you that is one
of the most fascinating and beautiful
topics
if you turn to science they will tell
you that 13.8 billion years ago there
was this big bang
and subsequent to that there were these
thick gases of hydrogen and helium that
fused together based on gravity and
built the universe as you know it
a wise person realizes that every single
moment of their life
what is unfolding in front of them is
the result of 13.8 billion years of the
universe unfolding and evolving until it
finally landed at their doorstep and
presented the moment that's in front of
them
to them so the world outside of you is
not of your own making
the world outside of you belongs to
science belongs to God it belongs to
Evolution it belongs to cause and effect
it is indeed the moment in front of you
took 13.8 billion years to get there you
can't call it your own you didn't make
it you weren't even here
the other way to know that the world
outside of you has absolutely nothing to
do with you it belongs to itself is to
realize that the moment in front of you
is no different than the moment to your
left or the moment to your right or the
moment behind you or the moment anywhere
else in the universe the universe is
expressing itself
everywhere you're just seeing one
particular moment one particular point
you can't say that because it's the part
that you see there's something special
about it it's just the part that you see
so a wise person comes to the point of
realizing that they are inside looking
out what is outside is the result of
creation it is not theirs it doesn't
belong to them it is just passing by and
they just happen to be seeing that
moment so karma yoga raises the Deep
question what then is my relationship to
the world that's unfolding in front of
me if it doesn't belong to me and it
doesn't again there's been one more
moment with that if I picked you up out
of the moment you're in
and dropped you onto a street in Paris
then that would be the moment you see
obviously that moment was there before
you got there and if I take you away the
moment will be there after you leave it
has absolutely nothing to do with you
eventually a wise person realizes that
it's true of every moment if I walk in a
restaurant
that restaurant existed before I got
there it was going on the people were
there conversations were going on music
was going on whatever food was going on
I then step in I'm just seeing a moment
that already exists when I step out the
moment will keep going on it doesn't
belong to me it belongs to itself
belongs to science belongs to God
it's such a beautiful thing to see that
the world outside of you exists
independent of you you are experiencing
one particular moment of it we call a
mindset it's a conditioning of the mind
that makes it so that things turn you on
and turn you off and that's where you
get your list of what you want and what
you don't want it is not true that you
want those things
what you want is something that will
open you so that you can feel the joy
that is natural when you're open and you
don't want the things that close you so
that you get blocked off from any joy
and you get this sense of depression so
you have a choice even right at that
point we haven't even gone deep yet you
have a choice do you want to spend your
life
deciding what you want and what you
don't want and then chasing it outside
or do you want to sit there and work
inside to realize all I really want is
the joy and the love and if I stay open
I can have those I don't need outside
conditions to keep me open so I make it
I make a very important point because in
spirituality it gets mixed up
spirituality is not about renunciation
there's no renunciation pronunciation
says I've decided what it is that will
make me happy and I'm not going to do it
well that sounds rather absurd all right
spirituality says it was stupid of me to
decide what will make me happy instead
of being happy with life instead of
being grateful and turned on by all of
the amazing things that are happening in
front of me and all the past experiences
I got to have why don't I just enjoy all
that and then come into life filled with
love filled with joy and give the hold
of my being to the moments that are
unfolding in front of me that's what
spirituality says so it's not about
renunciation it's not about things are
wrong and things are right
it's about understanding that you did
this you did this with your mind you set
up conditions in which your mind would
open and then your heart opens and
conditions in which your mind will close
and your heart closes so spirituality is
very positive you'll say spirituality is
not logical and rational it is so it's
saying to you why are you doing that if
you want to have a beautiful life spin
around a planet in the middle of
nowheres why don't you just open it's
your heart it's your mind it doesn't
need conditions to open it's just you
don't know how to do it it's you've
become used to programs uh habitual that
you had a past experience as by the way
this is where it comes from how did you
decide how did your mind decide what it
is you want and what you don't want you
did not make those decisions they were
programmed into you by your past
experiences all of them so you had a
past experience where something was nice
with a certain person they looked a
certain way they had a certain name they
drove a certain kind of car or whatever
it is and you really was really was high
for you it was beautiful years and years
ago now one of those things shows up you
meet somebody with that name as shallow
as that sounds don't kid yourself you
meet someone with the name of your ex
you close down even though it's not the
same person you meet someone with the
name of who you had your first date with
in high school that it was a wonderful
relationship and you open up and
likewise when you see a car they had a
nice experience in it turned you on so
you are programmed by your past
experiences such that if they were good
experiences they tend to open you when
something reminds you of them when they
were negative experience they tend to
close you and that is where you get your
list of what you want that's why all of
our lists are different everyone's
listening is totally different someone
tells you this is the same as yours
they're manipulating you because
everyone has had different experiences
and based upon those experiences it left
these Impressions on your mind and you
came up with this list of what I want so
when you make the list of what you want
what you don't want you're really making
a list of your past
yes how you came up with those things
even colors that you like anything
there are Impressions Skinner the
psychologist said man is the sum of his
learned experiences it's not true it's
true that your mind and your heart are
the your personal heart are the some of
your learned experiences but you are in
there noticing this so I make a big
distinction with BF right that you are
in there and you are noticing that your
mind is a some of your learned
experiences and it is that's what
psychology meets spirituality psychology
is right all of the psyche your thoughts
your patterns your likes your dislikes
your problems and neuroses Etc are the
some of your learned experiences but you
are in there you're the Consciousness
the awareness of being who notices that
what I'm saying is true
so basically you come to the point where
you have to decide do I want to continue
letting my past leave Impressions on my
mind and my heart such that only certain
things will open and close me and then I
will spend my life chasing after
manipulating controlling conniving
whatever you want
the world around me so that sometimes it
unfolds the way I want or do you want to
sit there and understand that you're the
one who's making these decisions it's
your mind who's setting up the
conditions why don't you just not do
that basically there are three
categories or groups of objects of
Consciousness that your Consciousness is
aware of one is the outside world if you
close your eyes you don't see the
outside world if you open your eyes ah
there it is okay it comes in I discussed
in the book goes deep tries to be
somewhat scientific so that we fit into
an intellectual model because everything
is logical and and intellectual and
reasonable so the fact of the matter is
most people don't think about this you
don't really see through your eyes your
eyes are sensors we call them senses but
they're sensors if they computer sensors
that are picking up light
turning it into signals that are being
sent up your nervous system you know
Optical nervous Optical nerves and then
it is rendering it inside your mind just
like you look at a flat scene scrap
excuse me a flat screen TV and you look
at it in there that's hard for us to
relate to because we're used our mind is
so intelligent that it creates 3D and
depth perception and everything even
though you're actually back in here
watching what's coming in and I like to
have fun with people I say I'll prove it
to you that it's really just light
that's bouncing off of objects and
coming into your eyes right turn off the
lights
and you won't see anything because then
there's no light bouncing off of things
that's how we think we think of drawth
life therefore I can't see no it's
because I turned off the light there's
no light bouncing off the objects and
coming reflecting back into your eyes
it's kind of neat isn't it all right so
it's it's fun to talk about this stuff
so one thing of the three new circuits
is there's an outside world with all of
its objects and there's a lot of objects
out there the second is that's not all
you receive inside not all you're aware
of inside you're also aware of thoughts
which I'm sure we'll be talking about
deeper so just surface level it you're
aware of thoughts that go on in there
are you not right you you notice your
thoughts are talking to you notice you
can make your thoughts think different
things so you the Consciousness the
exact same Consciousness that is aware
of the outside world is aware of your
thoughts they're not separate not
categorizing it this is the
Consciousness here's my thoughts that's
the Consciousness this is the world you
can do them both at the same time
they're looking at something and
thinking about it and your same
conscience is the same both and then the
third is your emotions which are quite
different than thoughts and I'm sure
we'll talk more about that but basically
emotions or feelings their vibrations
that come up they're not thoughts or
thought forms you actually see a boat in
there you can see you know see words but
you can hear words they're talking to
you their voice inside your head
emotions are like that they're just
basically shift in energy patterns
vibrations that you pick up but they're
very strong and they catch your
Consciousness so those are the three
things in the three things Circus the
outside world that you're aware of the
thoughts that are inside your head your
mind and the emotions that emanate from
your heart and the Consciousness gets
distracted by those things that's so
it's really funny that the word
distraction becomes a spiritual word if
you want to think of it that way but
deep spirituality deals with
distractions that's what it's all about
if you weren't distracted by your
emotions distracted by your thoughts or
distracted with the outside world you're
sitting in samadhi the Consciousness
would be able to come back into its
source all you can be responsible for is
yourself your starting position is right
you have to evolve with the different
situations that are presented to you and
my experiences if you do that
the rest will happen the people around
you will be raised naturally understand
that like if you bring anger into a
situation imagine a household or is
always fighting if all of a sudden
somebody's not and somebody's bringing
understanding and love that's all they
have to do it will change things
all right but you you can't sit there
and say I won't change until everybody
else does
you know it's not going to protect
myself that doesn't work
right so that you're asking you like
there's no surprise you I said big
things all right it's like can it be
better of course it could be better but
it requires that everybody work on
themselves
because while they're not working on
themselves they're working on everybody
else they're just trying to manipulate
the world has its ebb and flows it has
its cycle and it should have its cycles
and you do not understand those cycles
and you will never understand those
Cycles how could you possibly do you
only see this tiny bit of life it's a
whole its Cycles are in harmony with its
Universal self you only see the way when
it passes by you say oh I shouldn't be
doing that why because it messed up my
face and the reflection that's why
you'll always do it in relationship to
you you want to know how wrong you are
every single time you say something's
good or bad or right or wrong or better
or worse or preferred or not preferred
I'm going to ask you based on what every
one of those things a relative term good
bad right wrong preferred not preferred
those are relative terms she doesn't
agree she doesn't agree everyone's got
their own thing don't they they're
relative and I'm going to ask you based
on what and if you're honest you're
gonna say based on Me based on my view
of the world based on my value system so
what who cares about your value system
there's narcissist us again there you
are looking into the universe and seeing
the reflection of yourself and saying
that's what matters so it's you just get
to the point where you stop putting so
much weight on yourself stop being
narcissist your face is just one of 700
billion things in the universe your
spiritual journey is about ceasing to
think that you matter it is about
ceasing to think that you are the center
of your Universe the universe is the
center of the universe it's about Lake
not about face it just keeps coming back
to the same thing you have to wake up to
that so your spiritual growth is not
about getting into yourself or changing
your views or duh you need to go in
there and mess around with your mind is
crazy your mind doesn't matter it's a
nothing you know how long it takes to
erase a hard disk just take a good
magnet pass it across it's gone so it's
just meaningless what you have in there
stop rearranging the darn thing what
matters is life itself God the universal
get to know her how by ceasing to be so
interested in yourself so when you look
into the lake of life and that's what
you're doing every minute of every day
you understand that you're looking into
the lake of life when you look into the
lake of life will you please stop seeing
yourself there's lots and lots and lots
of things out there stop seeing yourself
how do I know that I'm seeing myself I
will give you the biggest clue It Ever
Was it offends you you feel a change in
the force in the energy in the Shakti
flow sometimes you do don't you like
lots of times if you look out into this
Lake of life and it causes a change in
the flow of the chi inside of you you
have projected yourself into life and it
hits your projection I want this to
happen I want that to happen the cause
of suffering is desires Buddha it's all
the same teaching you are projecting
from inside out therefore the innocence
of life is hitting your projections
causing you to suffer causing change to
happen inside your piece it's disturbing
the peace you want to stop that you want
to find true spirituality you have to
let go of projecting yourself onto life
[Music]
oh I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Bruce Lipton
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there Consciousness is
creating your reality if you put a
picture of fear into your reality then
your biology Behavior will manifest
things to be afraid of because this is a
short statement but to me it's the most
powerful one